[Music]
adults devised a plan and follow it
[Music]
children do what feels good thank God
it's Friday oh god it's Monday says the
guy who's struggling with money his
whole life
adults devise a plan and follow it one
definition of maturity is the ability to
delay pleasure the Bible says no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
one of the things we struggle with in
our culture today is we have a manhood
crisis the would suffocation of America
but occasionally more often than you
might think I get to see a bright spot
you see when a man puts the good of his
wife the good of his country and the
good of his children ahead of his own
selfish boyish desires that's when we
know he's a man not a boy when a guy
sells his truck sells his guns and
serves his country in order to take care
of his wife and kid in order to get out
of debt in order to prosper that's what
you call a man little boys
stomp their foot with a red face and say
I'm not having my Trek I deserve this
you don't deserve anything unless you've
saved up and paid for it you bought
something you didn't deserve and that's
why you have debt adults devise a plan
and follow it children do what feels
good
that lasted every scream that guys
impressive he took the initiative he
brought home the idea he gently
carefully with kindness and love
presented it to his wife she bought in
the two of them together make a fearsome
team he sold his guns and his truck and
let me just tell you some of you ladies
don't understand that necessarily but
I'm a truck guy and a gun guy and I
admire a real man that will sacrifice
for his family you can get you some more
guns and you can get you some more
trucks but you only get one shot at
being a man well that's probably not
true you probably could choose to do it
tomorrow I guess and probably get a shot
every morning but you get a shot at
being a grown up you know some of the
Millennials call it I'm adulting now
being an adult has become a verb and
that's true if you're a woman or a man
isn't it adults devise a plan and follow
it children do what feels good I meet
men that are 18 years old I meet men
that are 65 years old I meet selfish
little spoiled brats of all ages and you
do too don't you
as a matter of fact I've actually been
both you ever had a good wine party I
didn't say wine I said wine you want
some wine is some cheese with that whine
have you ever done that I've done that I
used to think whining was a little-known
form of prayer but something about the
pain of going through losing everything
with Shirin and I and something about us
saying never again and I don't ever want
to be here again you hear him say that I
don't ever want to be here again
ever want to live like this again
something about doing that that grows
you up doesn't it and it makes you a
full-grown woman it makes you a
full-grown man an adult adults devise a
plan and follow it children do what
feels good does that mean it doubts
never do anything impulsive no it just
means we plan our impulses you know if
you're quit taking random stupid tiny
little road trips you could take a world
class cruise with what you spend on all
that stuff you know if you quit buying
cars you can't afford you can have some
nice cars
you know you quit you follow me I mean
this is this is really not rocket
science people but it just struck me
that guy
our last debt-free screamer there I'll
run into him occasionally I remember the
first time that happened many many years
ago I was teaching Financial Peace
University with an overhead projector
and a bad suit I used to teach it live
and we gather in a circle after I taught
the lesson and this great big old guy
he's a country boy from Kentucky and he
must have been probably six six six
seven and just solid and I watched his
wife who was a tiny little lady
beautiful little lady completely tear up
and tell the whole group in the small
group setting how proud she was her
husband had sold his knife collection
which was apparently a world-class knife
collection it brought like $10,000 I
mean it was legitimate let me tell you
if you're a good old boy from Kentucky
you sell your knife collection to take
care of your family for your family to
get out of debt you know what that means
means you're a man he put his family
first above his selfish a little boyhood
desires and oh by the way you can get
some more knives if you live like no one
else later you can live and give like no
one else and the giving is more fun any
but it is the answer to some of the
things that are bothering our culture
right now most people are so worried
about their own needs and their own
rights rather than worried about others
as part of what's breaking the civility
down where some of you people just have
completely lost your minds in the midst
of political conversations in the midst
of you can't have a discussion with some
of these people anymore they're just
nuts and all of that has to do with
selfishness and fear instead of serving
and strength think about it'll come to
you
adults devise a plan and follow it I got
a hold of a piece of research several
years ago probably about 15 years ago
when I was continuing to grow and work
on this idea of teaching people how to
handle money this show was getting very
popular and I remember the research that
said that the typical person who is
wealthy when they make a purchase
decision when they make any decisions
with money matter of fact when they make
almost any decisions they think about
how it's going to impact their lives 10
20 30 40 years from now broke people
think about Friday living for the
weekend that's kind of cute but it's
pretty adolescent and in that kind of
there's not mean there is there anything
uglier than a 58 year old party animal I
mean for the weekend I guess that's okay
if you're 18 but when you're 58 and it
time to grow up and it really at 18 it
in time to grow up I mean you're not 13
anymore
think about it folks we worship youth in
this culture instead of
perfect hair instead of gray hair but
maybe there's something lost when we do
that think long-term serve your family
live like no one else so that later you
can live and give like no one else no
discipline seems Pleasant at the time
but it yields a harvest of righteousness
[Music]
this is the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]